Напередодні 8-го травня - Дня пам’яті та примирення в селі Борівка Київської області були доставлені особливі листи.
79 років тому їх написали своїм рідним ті, кого під час нацистської окупації України вивозили на роботи в Німеччину.
Перший транспортний поїзд з робітниками, які йдуть працювати в Німеччину, відходить 22 січня 1942 року о 9-ій годині ранку з вокзалу в Києві.
У Німеччині "остарбайтерам" дозволяли писати листи додому. Після обов’язкової цензури вони навіть доходили до рідних.
Тисячі таких ще недоставлених листів, знайдених у поштових відділеннях після звільнення України, потрапили в руки НКВС.
Їх планували спалити, проте з незрозумілих причин залишили в різних архівах по всій країні.
Київські історики віднайшли ці листи з минулого на початку 2000-их.
Їхнє оприлюднення стало можливим з 2018-го року, коли сплинув термін їхнього таємного зберігання.
Київський обласний архів зробив цілу виставку листів, а історики-волонтери почали вручати копії листів рідним "остарбайтерів".
Від Домки до своїх рідних! Я жива та здорова, чого  вам бажаю. Я поки н а старій роботі. Робота не важка. На дошці цього року не мокла, як торік.
Нам будуть давати мільтові костюми, плаття та панчохи. В нас позавчора давали туфлі, такі , як великодні, на дерев’яній підошві.
І знаєте, яке в бараці життя? Що у кого є, то як не гуртом зносять, так крадуть. В мене взимку вкрали хусточку. Вишліть, якщо буде.
Що Бог дасть, то з тим  буду проживати…
Цей лист з минулого Наталя отримала від своєї 20-ти річної матері Домахи.
Жінка народилася через кілька років після війни, коли мати вдруге вийшла заміж. Перше заміжжя протривало усього два тижні.
Відразу після весілля чоловіка Домахи забрали на фронт, де він загинув.
А вже у травні 1942-го саму її нацисти, що окупували Україну, відправили на примусові роботи в Німеччину.
Жінка померла кілька років тому. Від своїх рідних вона не приховувала, як їй жилося три роки в нацистській Німеччині.
Ці фото в 1945-му вона привезла додому.
Ось, тут жила. Одразу, як приїхала, потрапила до бауерів, робили усю сільську роботу: їздили на полі працювати. Там були і сільські наші, і чужі.
І з Польщі, Франції. Багато військовополонених.
Олександру Ковальчуку 55 років. Він мало що пам’ятає з того, що його дід розповідав про війну, про те, як був у полоні.
Дід помер в 1973-му. Історики віднайшли в архівах лист Тихона Ковальчука своїй дружині з полону - це рідкісна знахідка.
Через 79 років рідні отримали також листа від доньки Тихона - Єви.
Її вивезли на примусові роботи, і вонапробула там, тоді  познайомилися з бельгійцем, і вона сюди вже не повернулася, залишилася жити в Бельгії.
Вона приїжджала сюди разів 5 із чоловіком та дітьми.
Тітка вже померла, діти її живуть в Бельгії. Стільки років пройшло, ніхто та нічого не згадував, і тут на тобі. Я дуже радий.
"НепрOSTi  листи". Так назвали цей проєкт київські історики. А почався він фактично з історії родини фахового історика Віталія Гедзя.
У 2002 році його рідна бабуся розповіла йому, що під час окупації в Німеччину були вивезені три її двоюрідні сестри: Тамара , Жозефіна та Нона.
Дві повернулися. Одна - ні. Бабця Віталія все життя чекала хоч на якусь звістку і дуже сподівалася, що її онук-історик колись це  з’ясує в архівах.
Коли відкрив цю папку, перша зв’язка листів, перший верхній лист - написаний тією бабусею, яка не повернулася з Німеччини.
Де вона розповідає і про своє перебування, те, що мала відносини з французом і вибирає між поверненням на Батьківщину, залишиться у Франції, бо боїться.
Коли я привіз листи матері та бабусі, то було повне щастя. І я побачив, яка це реакція, яка не отримувала цього листа і, хоча через багато років, але отримала.
Робота з цими історичними документами відкриває невідомі сторінки.
У перші два місяці окупації України, як встановили київські історики, деякі українці добровільно зголошувалися їхати на роботу в Німеччину.
Їм обіцяли гідні умови праці, їхнім рідним -  виплати в Україні.
Як історик я зрозумів, що перші 2 місяці з січня по лютий 1942-го  це були добровільні,
тому що людям в газетах так розписали, що буде рай, а тут робити ніде, тому багато хто повірив та їхав.
Але дійсно, коли приїхали в Німеччину, вони побачили геть іншу картину, ніж їм обіцяли.
А тому з березня 42-го поступово набуває примусового характеру.
Мешканці селища Борівка напередодні Дня примирення та пам’яті згадують не лише остарбайтерів. Як не дивно, вшановують тут і одну… німкеню.
Краєзнавці розповідають, як під час окупації староста-німець повідомив нацистам про двох місцевих юнаків-партизанів.
Усіх мешканців села за це  мали розстріляти ось тут, на місці цього парку, а село спалити.
Врятувала Борівку місцева етнічна німкеня - Реґіна Кох. Вона нібито примчала до села на ось такій бричці за лічені хвилини до страти.
Вона підбігла  до німецьких офіцерів. Вона довго з ними розмовляла німецькою.
Видно, не дуже погоджувалися, вона падала на коліна, вона цілувала їм ноги.
Люди нічого не могли зрозуміти, що тут діється. І раптом німці щось поговорили і відпустили людей. і поїхали звідси.
Видно, вона змогла поговорити, і все-таки була німкеня. Вони їй повірили більше, ніж комусь тут.
Цю історію Наталії Клименко розповів її дід. Краєзнавиця працює вчителькою в школі і щороку проводить уроки про Другу світову війну.
Проєкт "НепрOSTі листи", каже вона, допомагає викликати у молоді інтерес до минулого України через призму історій окремих родин.
Історики-ентузіасти сподіваються, що їм вдасться вручити усі віднайдені листи "остарбайтерів" їхнім рідним.
Наразі в архівах знайшли не менше 100 000 таких листів.
Усі вони мають бути оприлюднені на спеціальному сайті, який активісти планують створити у майбутньому.
Таким чином вони сподіваються допомогти багатьом сім'ям українських "остарбайтерів" дізнатися про долю їхніх рідних,
багато з яких так ніколи і не повернулися додому.